every day is like an etch-a-sketch you
sketch your etch and then you take it
off by shaking the board I know very
little about makeup I know about blush I
know about mascara I know about that's
it
you don't know where to start
apply foundation first there's no makeup
in here it's just a mirror and a pad
oh there's two doors that's way too much
just looks kind of like sunscreen I feel
like this is making me look worse this
is also what very prestigious men in the
1700 youth to do that's not a fact
that's a guess don't get it in your eye
I feel like I'm in photoshopping myself
in real life right now you realize how
wrinkly you are I don't know what a
concealer does but I'm gonna figure it
out okay
concealed I got a little there and then
you just kind of like ya back dude I'm
right Oh someone been pinching his
cheeks
whoo the happy boy you know going into
this I didn't want to look like some
1950s female movie star are you supposed
to like color it in you don't put on
your top lip you just put it on your
bottom lip maybe they're right where's a
tissue I know I'm supposed to bite on
that I can't get the little ones always
wanted like a little more dark and
defined eyebrows girls do this right is
this the thing that you put underneath
your eyelashes retractable pencil flips
ha ha
they're labeled just omit the lip line
so I kind of put too much lipstick
eyeliner on use cup you just add more
makeup god damn it
yeah honestly it just it just feels like
I'm putting on a mask I became what I
feared the most a monster you know when
I see a woman and they wear makeup I'm
like hey you spent time on that it's not
easy to get everything right that's
something I never thought about is
feeling the pressure of needing to do
something like this every single day
just to fit in don't think of this as a
chore think of it as a way to express
yourself and have fun with it and if you
don't want to do it okay
let Duden be a part of it Society I want
in on your makeup world this used to be
my face hi